of course that Drake experience like
going there did you go to his house yeah
oh wow yeah and does he have like how
many front doors does he have I feel
like he'd have like a front door and
then if you're they let like somebody
lets you into that one but it's not even
him and you get closer and closer and
finally he lets you in like a room yeah
we were in his house for probably like
probably 90 minutes or two hours before
I even saw him oh really yeah
yeah it was an insane awesome experience
he's my favorite artist ever wow ever so
like girl because he's been around
making like great music for 15 years
since I was in high school and they say
that's your most like your favorite
music of your life is going to be the
music that you heard when you're in high
school really they say that I don't know
who they are yeah
probably some gobblers but you know like
he just been like that guy for forever I
mean I grew up Lil Wayne was the best
Lil Wayne was like the goat and he was
the inspiration I think even for Drake
it's obviously Jake says it but um so
like Lil Wayne and Drake those are the
two guys and so 15 years down the line
or whatever 10 years down the line
um to be able to like meet him and like
go to his house and like me just like
who answered the door when you got there
not Drake huh no no no he has a dude his
security is insane good luck dude I
would like to see the [__] busting
boys try to to run up with their teeth
and there was some guns trying to get
that Drake dude good luck dude there's
so many he has the most security you
ever seen security uh yeah imagine more
wow
okay you're not getting to this guy no
chance but uh damn he was awesome I mean
and was there some chicks there with the
breasts or whatever I mean I'm sure they
were I didn't see him they kind of kept
us in the gym oh really yeah like there
was a gym it was like if you gotta use
the bathroom like you really gotta go
you can go but like you guys need to
stay in the gym we finished like 10 30 a
night he was like what are you guys
doing for dinner and we're in Toronto
it's like a Tuesday night and there was
nothing open there's only McDonald's we
were actually planning on going like
have a celebration at McDonald's
she's like oh no it's all I'll open a
restaurant for you guys or like whatever
I'll keep it okay like I'll keep a
restaurant open for you guys you like
call some restaurant we show up it's
already closed and they're just like
wow like Drake Shack it says Drake when
you get there on the sun yeah he's a man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one